[موسيقى]
اما فيما يخص مستقيه التقارير حول زياده
التعاوني بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
من وجهه نظري الولايات المتحده تحاول
ارسال الرسائل الى ايران مفادها اننا
عندما نقول ان الخيار العسكري متاح على
الطاوله فنحن نعني ما نقوله ولا يمكن ان
نستبعد عمليات عسكريه اسرائيليه مدعومه من
قبل الولايات المتحده اما ان كانت هذه
تقرر موثوقه ام لا فلا احد يعرف
[موسيقى]
مش هتنظري امريكا لا توجد معلومات
استخباراتيه كامله وفي امريكا ناخذ
التقارير الاسرائيليه حول البرنامج النووي
الايراني
وقدراتها النوويه ضمن السياقي ان اسرائيل
لديها لمصلحه في اقناع الولايات المتحده
للقيام بعمل عسكري ضد
ايران او اي دوله اخرى ونحن لدينا
معلوماتنا الاستخباراتيه
ربما واركز على كلمه ربما تبالغ في تقييم
التهديد الايراني لكننا ندرك انا اسرائيل
لديها مصالحها الخاصه ولا نعتبر كل ما
تقوله اسرائيل حقائق
[موسيقى]
وفقا للمصادر المفتوحه لم يفوت الاوان قبل
نحو سته او سبعه اشهر هنا قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاسبق يهود براك الى
ايران بوسعها صناعه القنبله وحسب معلوماتي
فان ايران ليس بوسعها صناعه القنبله حتى
الان وقبل شهر قال مستشار ايه الله خامن
انهم وصلوا مرحله صناعه القنبله اذا ما
قرروا ذلك وكما قلت فان اسرائيل لديها
المصلحه في المبالغه بالتهديد الايراني
وفي نفس الوقت ايران لديها المصلحه في
المبالغه بقدراتها
[موسيقى]